[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to the
lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout
it is wednesday 11 a.m pacific here in
san francisco california i'm mike
mccarty i'm here with a few of my
co-workers
jake jake decker what's up people are
saying you look good in that color shirt
thank you i don't know if you could tell
by the stream but i only saw like josh
said actually i think josh just pointed
out it was pink not white i saw like
three or four people say it
you look good
thank you chad you should wear it more
often
i wear it a lot i know you do that was
the joke pete brown what's up hey man
pete what do you do here what do i do
here uh i review video games and i tell
people to review games and i say review
it better
nice what game you're working on now
uh i just finished up playing momodora
reverie in the moonlight which is the
fourth in the series of these sort of
like
i guess you'd call metroidvania games
but this one has like dark souls-ish
type combat which is like you know just
i'm lumping together these very general
terms for these games but uh it works
and it's it's pretty good short cool but
good
we can expect a review yeah i think
probably this weekend yeah it's sort of
like a like a little pet project no one
asked me to do it but it's one of those
games i want to highlight kelly plaggy
hi it's me what's going on um
a lot attack on titan is happening soon
so i'm working on that yeah resident
anime expert that's me death no movie oh
my god don't even talk to me
what what is this yeah what is explain
this to me before we get into games
the uh death note live action movie
trailer or it's a teaser the netflix
original uh dropped and i'm really upset
because it's all wrong everything's
wrong there were cheerleaders there's no
cheerleaders light does not make out
with anybody in that anime i'm really
mad about it stupid i'm so upset wait
sorry who doesn't make out with anyone
light the main character his name's
light okay if you don't know anything
about death note it's about a kid who's
really smart in japan
and he gets a book that's you can kill
anybody by writing their name in the
book oh okay and but this one is like
he's apparently a player and he like
dates cheerleaders oh yeah and then
writes their name in the book
that's dark yeah
so the lights just pimp in this entire
movie um
yeah i mean i'm just uh it's the tone's
all wrong look at look at that yeah it's
not but what's wrong with that netflix
doesn't do anything bad so it's got to
be good right
get out iron fist is
faring well
slash no it's not just kidding yeah i'm
really upset all right so death note
i'll be sure to not check out that
trailer after the lobby see there's
there should be no making out the
there's no police cars anyway that's me
that's my introduction interesting
all right and if you're joining us in
the twitch chat or youtube chat we have
that up i'll be monitoring that the
whole time i do have questions about
persona 5 ukulele and mass effect
andromeda through twitter uh yeah we
have a lot to talk about first i want to
get to a giveaway that we usually do uh
we have jake decker oh now you want me
to hold that again uh yeah he was i was
kind of messing with him before we have
a couple of giveaways like we're like i
said we have a lot of like collectors
editions and
random pieces of
game memorabilia in our nick nick
margarita memorial library here at
gamespot uh go that way
get that on the camera there we have a
dota 2 special edition mouse and a mouse
pad for which to
scroll that smooth mouth mouse across
it's smooth
16 sorry
colors
features what 16.8 million colors keep
going what hit me with the specs so you
can no i'm not gonna do that
people wanna know this is a giveaway
that's all i know about it it's good for
30 million clicks uh uh the rival what
is it rival yeah i don't know it
yeah
optical
six five six thousand five hundred cpi
three million clicks cool oh i'm into it
uh anyway yeah if you're in the uh
twitch chat you can see the lobby
giveaway link right there uh if you
follow gamespot on twitter and then
retweet
the tweet about the giveaway later on
the week you could be selected for us to
uh give you that sweet dota 2 merch
swag whatever term you want to use cool
i do have a few news items i want to get
through before we get to the meat of the
show
but kind of a slow week for news
actually um
arisa the robot character from overwatch
is now live on all three platforms you
feel like playing her she's more with
tank character protects them she's not
in competitive play yet but she will be
soon you can kind of see some gameplay
here uh
her she doesn't attack the kind of it's
called halt it's kind of like uh not as
powerful but it's sort of like zarya's
graviton surge it pulls people in and
kind of locks him in place seems like a
cool character is the first tank to be
added to the game uh sombra anna were
both uh sombra was more offensive anna
was a support character
uh yeah so she arisa the like omnic i
believe the robots are called in
overwatch i could be butchering that but
yeah she is available if you want to try
her out i know ps4 nick margarita was
saying uh ps4 servers were down last
night so he never got the chance to play
but hopefully they're more stable today
and you could check more there's another
there's also like a patch update out for
platforms you can check that out on
gamespot.com we have a new story about
it go read that go check out arisa i'm
pretty excited to play her this weekend
uh moving on fallout 4 vr will
apparently be on the show floor at
e3 2017
um and according to pete hines who spoke
to todd howard so that's pete hines
bethesda's uh
what do you want like like head of mr
marketing yeah head of marketing at
bethesda said he spoke to todd howard
and
todd howard said it will blow our minds
take that with a grain of salt if you
want to uh here's the new store right
here
it's probably more
like legible than everything i just said
but yeah it was a hip-hop gamer was
doing an interview with pete hines uh
and then pete hines was talking about it
but yeah if your e3 is open to the
public this year if you happen to be
going you can check out fallout 4 in vr
we also spoke to todd howard about the
advantages of vr with open world games
in a recent interview when he got
inducted into the uh bafta hall of fame
sorry academy of arts and science
interactive sciences hall of fame so you
can go read that on gamespot as well
but that's pretty much it for news this
week pete do you have any news of any
sort
there's a new uh ghostbusters vr game
that launched today out of the blue oh i
just meant like it's your birthday
coming up yes my birthday is coming
up for the week celebrating going to
portland for the weekends
what are you going to be doing eating
what's that donut shop up there blue
star i mean the the one people i think
talk about is voodoo because it's like
we put some stupid cereal on your donut
it's
i take donuts like a little bit
seriously probably more than i should
is there a doughnut gang war up there
and you're just like blood and crips but
i don't know who and blue stars star is
like high quality like bakery donuts
voodoo is just kind of like
these are ridiculous don't wear blue in
the voodoo neighborhood is what you're
telling me yes
i'll probably go retro game shopping i'm
gonna go ice skating drink lots of
coffee sweet stuff like that it's gonna
rain a lot though cool i guess well that
sounds fun thank you i'm looking forward
to watching your cat oh yeah you're
staying on my place get the cat sit yeah
he's got he's got a pretty cute cat that
i've cat sit before and i have a camera
that keeps an eye on you at all times
yes on me not the cat
there's like a little freudian slip on
your part no i see you'll be scrolling
around you can talk to me through it too
can't you yes
that creeps me out yes
mike
sorry that's
a lot of weird things going through my
head um
what about you guys before we get into
the show anything exciting coming up
aside from
games that you're working on
um me and you have some stuff
oh yeah we do reboot yeah i'm trying to
get you to pimp our stuff and you're
just no i don't have anything well i
mean it's you're kind of taking a dump
on mass effect and i don't really want
to i'm not taking a dump on mass effect
i'm looking at it in a mature critical
way
that is true that is true but yeah uh
that goes up sunday at three mm-hmm
that's our show of reboot
it's uh like an opinion editorial show
that jake and i work on uh yeah so check
that out kelly what about you
um like i said i'm working on anime
stuff i just like how to watch where to
watch attack on titan season two if you
care about that um and
uh that's it i think
i'm probably forgetting something
i'm sure we uh we'll have a lot of stuff
coming out on gamespot we have a lot of
like zelda guides and whatnot going up
too mass effect starter stuff if you
want to get into that game which we're
going to talk about later on the show
first i want to get into yooka-laylee
kelly you mentioned it uh and then you
also talk a lot about banjo-kazooie and
two in the office and you agree with me
that kazooie is the inferior one of the
two don't talk to me
anyway before we get into that argument
which i'm gonna win what does
this ukulele the main question i want to
know is obviously it's the people that
used to work on banjo-kazooie and tui
when it was rare and they were working
on those as the three platformers kind
of uh n64 days but now playtonic has
formed its people that work there and
they're working on ukulele which
is very much
like an obvious spiritual successor to
banjo-kazooie but how much does that
translate into the gameplay from what
you've seen so far yeah so from what
i've played um i wouldn't say it's
really reference heavy i was surprised i
thought there'd be more references like
direct references to banjo games but
it's more in spirit and uh grant
kirkhope who did
composing for the original um return to
do sound design and composing for this
one so that is very much the same and
the menus are all the same um and so
it's it's very much banjo in style
rather than an actual
content if that makes sense but there's
also like at the beginning you can do a
quiz game so at the end of banjo-kazooie
there's like a quiz
final quiz thing grunty's furnace fun
because i know that whole game um
that that ending is one of the reasons i
don't like that game as much as tooie
i'm big nerd i love taking quizzes but
this is to win a game though
was it was like yeah the sats were those
a game to you i got a 2200 without
studying
2200 that's not possible 1600 was the
maximum the numbers you're not that much
older than me mike
the max for me was 1600 i promise you no
you're not that much older than me i
promise okay
all right anyway
in that case i got a really bad score
i should not have gone to college or be
here right now
um anyway but so there's uh like i said
it's mostly in um how it's done rather
than what the content is uh so far which
is a little contrary to what i was
expecting i was expecting more easter
eggs and i haven't really seen that the
ui looked
just banjo-kazooie exactly the same yeah
the sound effects are the same uh yuka
sort of sounds like sexy grunty when you
die in banjo-kazooie you know she's like
yeah
yep sounds like that
yeah it's very similar well yeah when
you're doing the actual when the
dialogue pops up it's it's those talking
heads next to those like lines of
dialogue scrolling and like comic sans
looking font
yeah what about the structure of the
game so far you said there's like this
hub world but from what i played a
preview last year it was still pretty
early uh build but
it seemed like it was more geared aren't
you unlocked rather than these areas
existing and they're item gated by like
jiggies or whatever it is in this game
aren't you getting pages that build on
the world itself they i forgot how they
explained it to me but do you have any
more insight into that yeah so it's less
linear not that banjo-kazooie is
strictly linear but um
basically you're finding pages instead
of jiggies uh it's a very similar
structure um but you can
unlock like an expanded version of the
world um so
like you'll you'll be exploring the
world and there will be a point where
you can't go any farther but you can see
like oh i'm supposed to go over there
but there's no way for me to get over
there um you have to spend the paint
like pages i think is what they're
called um to uh
to expand it and like open up a new
uh
a new area and then but you can also
choose not to do that and just go on to
the next world so you can do it in any
order you want
and i would like to point out that the
snake's name is trouser
[Music]
i don't get it
yeah um how's the camera because i
played the toolbox
i think whatever they released and the
camera was like not good and it was just
like this is the camera needs to be good
for this camera is janky so far
yeah which worries me
because 3d platformers are pretty much
made or broken by their camera i was
playing yesterday and i was capturing
and i was like whoever is going to edit
this footage is going to think i'm super
bad at this game because the camera was
just kind of flying all over the place
at some point some points and there was
also a weird thing where like one of
this is a tribal stack tropics i think
it's called and oh rip
that's called endless abyss that might
have been me playing i don't know um
but uh
there's like an area where the camera is
just fixed for no reason and so when you
come out of it
like the camera the camera like flew
around and i was like what's going on oh
also you have to um spray pollen on
these flowers yeah here's another very
banjo thing the uh transformations yeah
that uh mumbo used to do yeah
how'd that sounds like it feel
mechanically though from your initial
impressions um i mean it's very similar
it's all about collectibles um i think
my biggest um i wouldn't say concern but
the the thing i'm hung up on is uh would
i
enjoy it if i wasn't such a big banjo
person
um just because it's like a childhood
game of mine
and um the other thing is like i'm
playing this i'm sort of like oh man i
kind of just want to play banjo
and that's worrying me a little bit of
course i'm going to keep playing um and
i'm very early on in ukulele but uh
those are two big questions and then the
other question is like if you didn't
play banjo-kazooie like what does this
offer you sure
yeah it's kind of like
playing mass effect andromeda makes me
want to play mass effect 2. and i don't
know that that should be the case but i
don't know that's kind of like you know
i guess up to each person to judge but
overall so i i think you've played more
of this game than you can talk about
right now because your review will be up
when the umbra is april 4th so it's a
while out okay cool so you have a lot of
time to play that um
final thoughts based on the preview
going into like the next couple weeks uh
for say i'm a person who really likes
banjo kazooie and tui and i
am wondering whether this game is worth
my time so far obviously you can't you
don't have the full review but
is it promising so far overall yeah i'd
say so i think it does enough to try to
break away from the formula that might
be a little dated i mean i think they
took a lot of
steps to make it like a little less
linear and give you more options and try
to make it modernized but with that same
humor and flavor
so that part is promising to me and
i think definitely if you really enjoy
banjo it's probably worth
taking a look at cool you're playing on
what xbox one yeah cool
awesome so uh anybody if you want to see
more about ukulele we have a few
interviews about playtonic devs from
pretty much throughout the past year or
so uh we did like kind of do something
on whether it might spark another slew
of 3d platform games but uh if you're
interested in those if you're interested
in reading those you can go check those
out at gamesbot.com and like callie said
her review will be up on april 4th on
gamespot.com
another probably the next big game
coming out uh which a lot of people are
excited for is persona 5 which uh a few
people at the gamespot office have had
for a while now have any of them beaten
it a couple people in the uk cool yeah
tamar was saying lucy james over in the
uk i've played a lot of persona 5. uh
and
myself and i think i think all three of
you are persona fans am i correct
i'm
i tend to like the shin megami tensei
series a little bit more okay um before
i've played of this one i like it more
than other persona games cool i do have
a few uh like twitter questions about
persona but before we get into those
as someone who doesn't know anything
about the series i we went to lunch the
other day and i was asking you like
what's even the premise of this
franchise
sounds kind of like from what you told
me about the mechanics and the structure
it sounds like something i would
actually be into uh based on the other
rpgs similar to that that i do like um
but as a newcomer to the series i wanted
to know from what you've played and from
what you guys understand of it will it
be a good introduction to this series
for me yeah i mean like right off the
bat you don't need to know anything
about the previous games right like
there's no character there's like yeah
it's it's brand new cast new set i mean
they're always kind of set in japan but
this is like you know shibuya this is
like you know the heart of tokyo um and
it feels like a much more modernized
version of what you know persona's been
doing up until this point because like
persona 4 golden was a big hit on veda
but it was also a port of a playstation
2 game
so the last thing that we've seen from
persona is quite old at this point so
this game definitely looks like
something that you would expect today um
it so it is cross-platform with ps3 and
there are some moments where you're kind
of like oh yeah i guess maybe the game
looks like it could have been better but
maybe it was held back a little bit but
by and large i think it's the style that
really kind of gives it its edge
um you know where maybe the graphics
aren't like super impressive on a
technical level yeah for someone
unfamiliar with the series what's like
the main allure of it would you say i
mean it sounds like it's pretty
multi-faceted but yeah i mean like the
the primary thing is that you sort of
hop between this sort of like slice of
life day-to-day thing as a student in
high school and then you kind of dip
into this like dark like
alternate dimension where you have
control over magical powers and sort of
like an alternate personality that is
like a projection
of like your inner self and they are the
persona
um i guess you could compare them to
stans from jojo's bizarre adventure
maybe
yes anime anime oh god this is the first
one too that has uh it doesn't have
procedurally generated dungeons right
like the dungeons are actually from what
i've seen so far they seem to be set in
stone were they procedurally generated
before and persona 4 they were okay
because i didn't get too far into that
because i didn't actually like the
day-to-day oh really that that was my
favorite part of that game because a lot
of people loved it i love slice of life
all about slice life that's that's my
jam
i think it's just persona 4 felt like it
got to a kind of a slow start or like a
rolling start
like a really slow roll
this one i kind of like it because
you're you're basically shipped off from
your hometown because god
because you you stopped the crime from
happening but the police are sort of
like looking at you as someone who
intervened when they shouldn't have and
therefore you've been kicked out of your
school and so you're shipped off to live
with this guy who runs like a little
restaurant um and yes he kind of like
doesn't really like you even though he
volunteered to take you in
um he's really unsure about you and he's
constantly giving all these warnings
like look man you're on your last straw
like you screw up you're out of here
um and so you kind of feel like at odds
uh with everything um but then you feel
like almost at home when you go go into
that
the alternate dimension as it were uh
where things become a little bit
less tied down your character or more
about uh the people around you and what
they think of themselves sounds like
high school yes
i think somebody mentioned in the chat a
while back but uh my good friend andrew
goldfarb over at ign beat the game in
japanese um so if that's any indication
of whether you can approach this game as
a newcomer he does not speak japanese at
all so
uh he was just able to get through it um
so that kind of says a lot to me about
the accessibility is that enjoyable
he is the biggest persona fan probably
in the entire world
like like this game definitely it like
it's stylish and like you know the menus
look great and stuff like that and some
of the character avatars but there's a
huge variety of monsters in this game
and some of them are throwbacks to the
past but they're just like really
strange concoctions so like pretty much
everything you're looking at at all
times is like kind of intriguing in one
way or another so i think even if you
don't know japanese the combat mechanics
mixed with the design of the world and
the enemies is probably enough to keep
you going i would worry about getting
lost and not knowing where to go
me too i mean i'm sure he consulted
people because i know a couple people
who played in japanese and uh different
different levels of japanese knowledge
so he probably asked people for help too
but i think he's trying to platinum it
in japanese and in english
because that's just how andrew is love
you andrew um the other thing i like
about persona is uh
just getting to pick your best girl
who's your persona 4 best girl
i'm not that deep in yet i've only
played about five hours or so so i'm
just getting started at school i'm just
sort of like
people are starting to get to know me as
the weird kid the out-of-towner that
kind of thing sounds like a historical
drama
i was making fun of you not me i know i
was just kidding i was a weird kid i
still am
i want to know who who mike's best girl
would be that's why i want you to play
this game i want you to play persona 5
so you can tell me who your best girl
well let me ask you who you think my
best girl would be uh i think the i saw
a girl in a cat suit that one uh i'm on
board right now but
explain her what's with her personality
i don't know enough about her
personality i've literally only seen her
in that she's like maureen she's she's
presented early on as a very interesting
character who's kind of like a pivotal
character uh
as you're learning to cope with your
powers and understand like the
situations you're thrust into
because essentially like you just have
the cell phone and you're walking around
this new part of tokyo to you and this
icon keeps appearing and you're like go
away get out of here but it persists and
that's the sort of thing that triggers
you going to another world and
she's involved as something in the real
world which then dictates sort of the
behavior of everything in that alternate
dimension okay um
it's very it's very interesting like how
quickly this game presents a conflict to
you that's
that's really like oh [ __ ] like that's a
thing in this game like and they just
roll with it i don't want to spoil it
it's not like a huge deal but it
certainly sets an interesting tone early
on okay well i'm into the cat girl right
now
jake what is your do you have like a
have you played any other ones besides
four nope just persona four golden that
seems like the one that correct me if
i'm wrong kind of justified everyone's
vita purchase that's why
i heard that's the reason i should get a
beta so i gotta be to play that's what i
did it also seems to be the most um
pervasive persona game
or at least maybe in the west or am i
wrong that's tough to say i mean three
and four both had a huge following like
in japan it led to anime series and
movies and stuff like that and we've
even i guess
three
well at least four had its own dancing
and fighting games made the dancing game
was kind of whatever right yeah but that
fighting game was really good made by
arc system works uh that game was
actually great for a spin-off title
um
but yeah in the west i don't i think
four was really the first time that it
kind of caught uh mainstream attention
so you can during the combat your party
will consist of all personae or
well so you have your own abilities and
weapons but then you can call upon your
personas to do that i don't know i was
just countering you
uh you can call up call upon your
personas to do certain uh things for you
okay um and you can also negotiate with
the demons that you're fighting it's
another kind of core mechanic that
came from the shin megami tensei series
which this was born from
um it's a persona seems to have the
spotlight now but shumigami tensei was
the first
okay yeah cool
i mean everything i'm seeing looks like
something i've been getting into
like rpg i mean i've always liked rpgs
but i've been getting into more rpgs
lately and uh i think the last one i
really grinded with was uh
uh what was the
i reviewed it and it's escaping me right
now
um
bravely second thank you so much and i
liked it uh yeah and i think that was
the last one i really put time into just
grinding through and getting every uh
class for the characters right every job
sorry they're called in that game uh
getting the pirate the cowboy the just
like everything you can imagine honestly
and i really like the variety of that
game which usually seems like a cop
output was there a hairdresser class
you said everything i could think of
from
the barista class just like
badass and that was my main thing um oh
jake have you played five yet at all
persona five not bravely fifth
no i have not played persona five at all
i'm looking forward to it yeah this
might this this seems like the game that
i want to like make myself get into
because uh the rpg i wanted to dive into
was mass effect andromeda and for those
just joining we haven't gotten to that
yet we will be talking about it um
but i do have a few questions about
persona 5 for people here on the lobby
cast um
first from our friend guptu riot a
frequenter of the lobby chats and
streams here at gamespot uh is there any
word on new game plus yet
i don't know about that okay and it
might be something we can't even talk
about if we did know yeah i don't know
um he is a multi-tiered question uh how
do you have an idea of how many
characters there will be throughout the
play through i don't or how many have
you encountered so far in your time with
the game cali or pete um i've
encountered two characters that are like
in your party okay beyond the main
character yes am i i don't sorry three
actually
oh three
hold them back peter
it's just like stop lying it's like a
spoiler no
i'm just forgetful oh okay um and then
also
he yeah goo best who is bae
[Music]
whatever her name is she's perfect and i
love her the cat lady the cat lady
so are you just saying she would be my
no i think she's perfect but i okay
persona 4 resay all the way
i don't i don't mess with chi a don't do
that explain both of these people to me
i don't remember persona before that
much but i'm pretty sure was mine as
well
[Laughter]
someone in the chat was just mentioning
before we move on
uh the persona 5's art direction and
just like the overall art direction of
the series but persona 5 specifically
looks pretty cool
it's definitely matured it's like i
think three and four kind of followed a
very similar path um but this one
definitely is embracing like
jazziness i don't it's hard to i can't
take anything you're saying seriously
yeah it's a jazzy a jazzy like comic
book style yeah which sounds right up
one of my alleys it's very very stylish
yeah um yeah i do have one more question
a little more from lloyd chris one more
serious question
i didn't write this lloyd christmas yeah
on twitter he tweets at me every once in
a while i really like that name that's
his real name that's awesome but
probably not
you know him not his name oh he's the
one he like he made me taunt this guy
okay
uh from lloyd christmas on twitter thank
you very much for sending your question
goob thanks thanks to you as well uh
goobs here in the chat i'm sure he'll
have other questions uh lord christmas
do you think persona 5 can have the same
commercial success today
that something like final fantasy vii
did when it released no absolutely no do
you think anything can uh no i i if
finally well zelda maybe right like
final fantasy 7 was a game that came
along it like it struck but the iron was
hot like just at the right time and did
something that no other games were
really doing and had a lot of marketing
money put behind it um and sort of broke
free of i think the audience that
typically goes for these games why are
you all smiling because that's still out
there
um
yeah resa i think we'll see persona 5 do
well for sure but i don't think it's
going to be sort of a revolutionary game
okay does it work anybody else contend
with that
yeah i think it's too it
it's just
niche enough to not um
be able to get the same traction i think
okay yeah
you want to know something
embarrassing you've never played final
fantasy 7 that or any other final
fantasy game i played two hours of 15.
i've never played a final fantasy either
oh yeah chris waters had never played
one and we had him review the third
final fantasy 13 game
how's that going that sounds like a good
review
it was amazing watching him react to all
the things it just didn't make sense to
even fans did he like it uh i think he
walked away with like a seven or six
okay yeah i don't know i forget but uh
you guys should play final fantasy game
oh chess i want to play six very badly
huh final fantasy 13 3 no
chastity says the cat girl's name is
anne ann and she's perfect that changes
things bland
yeah
she does this thing it's so cute she
calls it a man egg
puts a hard-boiled egg in her mouth
all right i'm gonna move on if only to
get that graphic off the screen uh boy
christmas thank you much so much for
your question
and goob as always thank you for your
input and uh so persona 5 release date
uh it's coming out april fourth year
before we'll hit march 29th from lucy
james in the uk in the uk uh so yeah you
can stay tuned to the game spot for that
we'll have uh sherlock videos and uh
stories about the game coming out before
its release uh as in uh it's western
release it's been on japan since
september and i've seen japan likes it
yes
cool so for those of you excited for
that that is kind of i think that's our
like i don't know like kind of
subjective but i think that's the
biggest next release after yeah yeah
there's a few end of april's pretty
packed
with like me with mid-tier stuff yeah
yeah but persona 5 is going to stand out
and then pray i think will be the next
one that gets people talking cool but
hopefully persona 5 is interesting to a
lot of people cool so yeah say uh
gamespot.com as we approach the release
of that game
all right
game of the hour oh here we go
all right there's a lot of people
talking about mass effect in the chat on
youtube and twitch
for those joining
we are gonna get more into mass effect
specifically but first i want to kind of
lean into it
if it kind of hints at my uh take on the
game i want to talk about other aaa
games that kind of had rough launches
for one reason or another and whether or
not they fixed
said problems at release
and maybe can mass effect learn from
them and or maybe have the same success
in subsequent weeks or months after
release uh but anyway yeah
i mean
mass effect is out we will talk about
more specifically uh but it's kind of
having a rough launch i mean there's
been i think gifts about its poor
performance technically are kind of
being
uh overblown and they're really funny
but i think there are bigger problems
again than the technical problems but as
it stands now
it's kind of buggy to say the least uh
you just saw there
i think that was john luke typekey his
uh
gameplay of mass effect andromeda he's
enjoying this game i believe from for
the most part and he was talking to
drac the krogan your krogan party
character in this game and another drak
came out of the drak he was talking to
he started wandering the room and then
afterward
he's gonna have to correct me if i'm
wrong but he could
i'm pretty sure he could talk to both of
them
and that's not supposed to happen and
then i was talking to uh brad over at
giant bomb he was saying that he
restarted the game to try something out
i don't know if it was a different
platform or what but he restarted the
game and
when your character wakes up from
cryosleep like right when you get
control
there's krogan's writing from the sky
right when you get control of your
character uh sarah or scott ryder
whoever you choose from cryosleep you
know the idea of being they're sent to
the andromeda galaxy they've been in
crowdsleep 600 something years uh they
left right after the events of mass
effect 2 but before the events of three
how many farts built up in those 600s
yeah i know you just wake up and just
rip that's the why the nexus is failing
because it's filled with methane gas but
a character npc
was next to
uh there was an npc next to him when he
woke up and he talked to him and he
recognized the dialogue from his other
playthrough that was a character from
later in the game that gives he's a
quest giver and he was there next to his
character right at the beginning and
should not have been there and he gave
him the quest complete dialogue from
like four hours later that's not good
yeah what that sounds weird yeah and
then uh
jean-luc again was capturing some stuff
and he was talking to uh this is a
conversation happening with with a wall
and whatever that object is yes
he was talking about
if you're if you're wondering why we're
showing boring footage like this that's
because this is what we saw when we were
playing uh you know you fight the cat
here and this is like i said at least
there's some funny videos and there are
gifts and whatnot of like pb the asari
character holding your gun the wrong way
i hate pb
and there are other problems with this
game and again we'll get into those here
are the two drax right here um just kind
of hanging out he
just spontaneous clone bustion happened
and now here he is both of his versions
talking to him but
oh man i got off track because of this
footage we can use more of this in a
little bit um
but i want to talk about other aaa games
with rough releases the first one that
comes to mind that was pretty
broken was assassin's creed unity do you
guys remember that when it released oh
yeah did you play it no no i
i played it like when it was 20 later
down the line yeah it was just like even
then it was still broken and it was just
it wasn't a very good game too so this
was when i was kind of falling off the
assassin's creed train you lasted a long
time well it was like longer than most
yeah cause uh black flag was one right
before this correct form
yeah yeah and
i liked it and i really liked black flag
but not for like assassin's creed
purposes
this game was rough when it released it
was like you sometimes you just get like
clip into crowds and get stuck when like
half the game
no more
all right well definitely watch the
video i missed my flight
um
and this dude posing yeah this is he's
using something
some sort of ice sword this is the
famous hairball guy right with like eyes
in the hair yeah
oh yeah i hope i don't know if john luke
has footage you could pull up of that
horrifying face guy that they showed it
first he doesn't pull that off uh but
yeah this game i mean i didn't really
like this game outside the bugs but this
was rough when it was amazing
they started subsequently repairing it
after they released uh but it still
wasn't that great of a game but oh here
we go is he gonna keep climbing nope
nope
try again nope
oh man yeah so the guy with the freaking
face like in this lapel through his
mouth this is not a rough launch but to
ubisoft's credit they did repair it in
the subsequent weeks uh i don't
know what state it's in now but
it just didn't
really uh hit home at release i could
watch these all day yeah how are you
talking about watching
i don't know i'm struggling
[Laughter]
not getting knocked down
[Laughter]
here's the montage of these it's like
the i don't
know paralysis or whatever in like
oblivion or skyrim and they just freeze
and they just roll down a mountain yeah
the opposite of ragdolling you just
tumble the end over icy limb
uh
okay gonna try to move on from unity if
possible so unity they did uh do some
repairs to it
some like numerous patches uh it still
took a while but i guess they made it
better technically i don't still really
like that game but at least they you
know fix major problems people have it
another one which is more due to
multiplayer servers in general was
battlefield 4. this is a big one because
like i don't like for me i got an xbox
one at launch and i got battlefield four
and that was it didn't work so i was
like all right well i got this xbox one
[Laughter]
17 is very very it's still not done so
don't
take that but you can uh look up just
look up mlb 17 face glitch i mean the
dev [ __ ] yeah
the devs shared them like they had a
good sense of humor about early
that was a that what we just saw was a
release game but battlefield 4 was just
not working and it like the campaign was
well the campaign too like i think i it
like it wouldn't save my game i'd play
like four or five hours of it and then
it would delete my game and i'd be like
okay i guess i'll try again so i try
again and like my friends were like yeah
i beat it but i just did in one sitting
because it kept happening to me as well
so it's like
the game was broken yeah uh and do you
remember how long it took to fix
uh i don't know it was it was weeks
right like i think i played it again a
couple months after and it worked but
like yeah it was probably weeks if not
months
yeah aaron sampson
he's like a resident military shooter
but especially battlefield expert and i
remember him talking about it he was
saying super disappointing
don't ever mention bad company to him
because he'll talk forever about how
good that game is but like when on the
rare occasion he talks about another
battlefield he's talking about
battlefield 4's broken launch and i
remember when i first came to gdc in
2000 uh 2013 in san francisco
it was like a massive battlefield 4. it
was the battlefield 4 reveal it was just
that was like the biggest
uh like ad they had over at moscone
convention center and then like a few
months later just the game was destroyed
at release yeah but they did fix it it
took a long time did not release in
great shape
um yeah i guess
good on them down the road but uh all
right destiny this is different because
this was not
technically made massively flawed at the
beginning i mean yeah it wasn't like
broken but uh a lot of people had
problems with vanilla destiny um and a
lot of that was rectified with taking
king
but um i mean you know replacing uh
dinklebot um
wait what's the what's the famous line
that wizard came from the moon one
wizard came from the moon
i don't know like who was directing
those voice acting sessions but uh
yeah so
yeah so the interesting thing there is
because it's uh
you know
a multiplayer game and
that's the main conceit of it um it's
constantly evolving so uh
i liked that they
took steps to
um fix problems that weren't necessarily
like game breaking problems but that
were hurting people's enjoyment of a lot
of things you could do by yourself um
and so i think that was an example of
something that i mean
regardless of how you feel about destiny
it definitely improved over time um
and so it's an example of something that
like oh they fixed a lot of dialogue
problems and um gave the story a little
more interest
and i enjoyed taking king a lot i played
all of taking king yeah mechanically
destiny felt awesome right away it still
does but i also was playing it just for
the sake of it i didn't really love it
but then yeah i like taking king a lot
too for the how it changed the structure
of the game
um yeah and yeah and also the fact that
they were poised replaced that voice
acting and kind of like wrote a whole
new script for uh
who was it troy nolan north nolan north
yeah nolan north did uh your ghost and
uh yeah no they fixed it i think uh i
don't i didn't really like rise of iron
but maybe that was just because you know
comparison to taken king which revamped
destiny kind of uh paled in comparison
well yeah rise of iron wasn't a
completely new exp like it didn't add as
much as taken king did but it also
reused a lot of assets and so all of the
the enemies and rise of iron were just
like slightly altered reskins and the
areas were reskins and so that's what i
didn't like about it it was very
repetitive to what i'd played before in
a way that a different from how destiny
is naturally repetitive i guess um so
yeah rise of iron was like a step
not down for me but it just was like oh
this i just am happy with taking king i
just want to play taken king sure the
the raid was good yeah
uh
and then in terms of another rough
launch it's very different because i
it's very different because i think this
is based more on
pre-release marketing and what people
expected
but uh it might be worth talking about
no man's sky hmm a game you liked
i did like yeah yeah um but i it wasn't
a game that i was really excited for
going into it it was one where it was
kind of like okay i'll review this and
i'll find something interesting to like
keep myself you know
or just to get excited about and what i
found early on was the atlas path for me
that made the game super fulfilling and
everything around it was kind of just in
support of that which is great uh but i
think a lot of people were expecting
this like you know
once in a while you'll meet someone from
the other side of the universe that's
another player and you can like share
all these things and yeah that didn't
happen um so i didn't really find that
terribly disappointing but uh certainly
a lot of people did and uh
hello games has you know gone to great
lengths to sort of add stuff
that aspect still really isn't there i
don't think yeah um but
i mean did you guys play jake you played
right i played a lot of no man's sky did
you like it despite it not having those
things yeah i mean i tempered my
expectations quite a bit i'd say um like
i know a lot of people who are mad about
are expecting like
this grand adventure with this great
story and like all these different
characters you'll meet along the way and
like maybe you'll come across a
civilization instead it was just kind of
like but the act of exploring and like
especially like
taking off in your ship and like and
that's something that's really was a
granite yeah i think yeah and like i
mean just like the the idea like the
atlas path in particular the fact that
you're like traveling through like
dozens if not hundreds of different
solar systems with planets the size of
like i don't know how big did they say
that they were like
huge planets like it's
it's quite the adventure i think when
you look at it like that it was pretty
impressive but then also you know it
seems like a lot of people who were
excited couldn't just look at the game
at face value and i think enjoy it for
what it was um so yeah different from
these other examples but i think it's
it's sort of that like what do fans
expect right
yes i mean like in best case scenario
like in destiny i think is a good
example like kelly mentioned taken king
uh whether it was an expansion or dlc
uh these games kind of you know like
improved in the aftermath um others that
were technically glitchy at first
obviously you know in 2017 unfortunately
a lot of games are released
without
the polish that we used to expect i
think now because you can get day one
patches and whatnot or sometimes you
know like in assassin's creed unity it
could take a while battlefield 4 could
take a while but
thankfully most of the ones we just
mentioned were kind of improved in the
aftermath but
let us know if we forgot any especially
ones that did kind of get fixed in
subsequent weeks or months after its
release
let us know in the youtube comments or
in the chat as we move on with the show
now
let's get really into mass effect
andromeda
uh scott butterworth at gamespot you can
go read his review he gave the game a
six out of ten uh he played i don't know
like 60 hours or something total yeah he
still had a he's playing a lot more
yesterday just to check it out but he's
on vacation a well-earned vacation after
pax and reviewing that game for us but
we uh at the office all kind of have
differing opinions on this game uh some
of us are really diehard mass effect
fans some of us are kind of coming to it
fresh uh
die hard yeah and
we wanted to talk more about it but also
we kind of wanted to branch off the
games we're just talking about to kind
of suss out whether we think mass effect
andromeda
might be improved down the road um
i just want to get initial impressions
here at the table first kelly you're
like
sorta early in the game i'm pretty sure
early still yeah but
um i think my biggest problem is the
writing
for a lot of the dialogue yeah um so
just to get that out of the way still to
dial yeah we can get more into it but i
mean it's like especially the flirting
stuff is like my 13 year old fan fiction
like it's real bad yeah
it's like oh you know when you're like
13 you think being awkward is very
charming and you're like i'll just try
to be extra awkward and it's like no
don't don't try to do that she's no
writers know anne from persona no
see i know personally i can do it she's
gonna name drop she's no best girl but
jake uh you like mass effect a ton
you're doing well you're i'll pimp
something quick you're doing the saddest
party in the citadel explain this to me
uh so jean-luc and i are actually
playing through the end of mass effect 2
we've actually already done that we're
on mass effect 3 right now we're just
trying to kill as many of our companions
as we can it's rough like we just killed
i don't want to spoil it we killed a
certain character and it
kind of broke my heart i regret doing
this whole series was it garrus well
that was sad but like that was like a
quick death like he got shot in the face
with a rocket and it's like okay are you
talking about when they force you to cut
off morden's head with a saw well
it is the character in question but that
doesn't happen this is the game i want
to play yeah that sounds good it's like
a word you kill everyone um
but yeah so i'm a big mass effect fan i
do like andromeda i think andromeda
there is a lot wrong with this game i
think the writing is the biggest defense
um because like when you play a bioware
game that's what that's what you expect
like good writing good story good
characters and all of that kind of falls
flat which is a huge shame um there are
some characters that are okay there's
some characters that are good and there
are some like dialogue sequences and
like certain aspects of the story that
are really cool
but when it boils down to it like i
think scott actually mentioned it in his
review that like
a lot of that game needed to be cut
um like the good stuff is buried and i
think that's very true like
i played i think i'm at like 30 hours or
now and there's probably about like four
or five missions where i've like really
enjoyed as opposed like mass effect 2
where every mission was like had its own
story had its own arc and it had like a
cool location and this it's like
all right so i'm flipping switches on a
planet and that leads to something else
like i don't like i'm i'm i've been
playing a sudoku puzzle for like the
past 45 minutes explain that quick how
that works well not sudoku how sudoku
works i've been waiting five years for
this game and i'm doing sudoku puzzles
yeah no that's like the hacking and
these remnant terminals you come across
i think i don't it's not a spoiler now
you know there's like
an ancient civilization that's all i'll
say but like the hacking in this game is
a sudoku puzzle yeah like before the
show jake was trying to do one he's like
just swearing at his computer and it's
not that they're hard it's just what why
am i doing sudoku exactly there's some
simple ones that take you like i don't
know like a couple minutes it's like
that's fine you know that's a nice
diversion but then there are other ones
that i'm at for like
20 30 40 minutes and it's like
this just brought this game to a
grinding halt yeah um i liked
my theory was that in the andromeda
galaxy the remnants to protect
their technology
thought this like really clever puzzle
would protect it but then
all of a sudden these aliens from a
galaxy where that's like sold at gas
stations comes in it's like this is
sudoku
it's like it's like a word search is
there and then you're like oh sweet i
just gained access to this
i didn't spoil it i think though cause i
did just like
i guess kind of [ __ ] on mass effect
andromeda a lot and like to be fair i am
enjoying this game i am a huge mass
effect fan so and maybe it's some maybe
it's rose tinted glasses because like
it is cool being back in this universe
it is cool seeing a lot of
these different races again seeing that
interaction between the different
species and i think the worlds are
really cool like you get to one later
called eledin
um
which is by far one of the coolest
settings in a mass effect game i would
say at least in terms of an open one
um and there's like six or seven
different planets you can explore some
are huge some are smaller but doing that
is really cool and it makes me i just
wish everything supporting those cool
areas was also cool
but if you're a mass effect fan like i
think you'll enjoy it yeah so one thing
that you know
when scott's reviewing the game he's
just judging the game on its own merits
right it's a review but
a lot of people think that
we're disliking andromeda because in
comparison to mass effect 1 2 or 3 it's
worse but
i am i love those games but i didn't
come into this from like a fan side i
came into this and i just objectively
don't like this game for a lot of
reasons like callie mentioned there's
still to dialogue i don't think there's
much momentum to the plot despite the
fact that the idea of us being the alien
coming to a new galaxy and not being
visited is really cool whereas you know
mass effect 1 2 3 was really cool
premise in that it's this galaxy that
has already come to grips with the fact
that there's alien life and it's got a
galactic government there's like you
know different species are helping each
other out or at war or have their own
problems that like humans know about
this game is just it's all brand new and
it fell into so many
not just like sci-fi tropes
but also
video game tropes like i immediately
felt like i was thrust into combat for
no reason there wasn't anything
interesting about the arrival in the
andromeda galaxy unless you went around
and like maybe one out of eight npcs was
had something like actually interesting
problem that didn't exist in mass effect
1 2 3.
these people just left everything they
knew behind
and
i don't know they seem fine immediately
uh i did character creator side note
don't do character creator if you don't
want your dad to look like uh
a offspring of jeff goldblum and william
h macy if they kind of like had an
affair on the side yeah he looks i don't
have footage of it thank god if i did i
would scrub my computer
so much
it doesn't look good because they kind
of like take this amalgamation of
i think i could be wrong i think they
take what your
twin looks like because you if you pick
sarah ryder scott ryder will be your
twin and they take what both of us look
like and kind of combine it and what
happened to mine was just
a monstrosity mine looked a little bit
like edward james almost oh nice so it
was fine i was like oh the battlestar
galactica feel yeah it's never a bad
thing yeah i
but like i said they're writing this
game it's just between the dialogue i
don't think the the pacing is great
because you're getting distracted by all
these side quests the side quests i have
problems with uh you said you did four
or five missions which are interesting
to you that's you've got four or five on
me like i i didn't really enjoy any of
them that i played um yeah i mean well
how far are you though um i did you're
still on eos correct before no no no no
i did the next
oh i'm on the
you're i did the next two i did the
other two i did those two i'm on the one
after that
kadara i'm doing this stuff after vold
and havarl
oh okay so i mean i don't think i'm as
far as you but i'm into the game um and
like i said this kind of reminds me of
uh dragon age inquisition in that i'm
doing so much that doesn't matter
and you know i'm not judging it based on
how it compares to horizon or zelda but
those games like i was exploring because
there there was stuff the stuff you were
doing like contributed to your character
or there's it felt meaningful within the
world this stuff just feels like it's a
checklist uh i was reading review over
at kotaku today i think and i think
patricia hernandez was saying
it
reminded her of a really full email
inbox and it overwhelmed her and she
didn't know like which one to pursue
first and which one to actually kind of
prioritize
um and i don't i they tell me that the
nexus is
you know like it's things aren't going
well i'm trying not to spoil anything
and i won't but you know things aren't
like going according to plan that's been
evident from the trailers and everything
and but they don't convey that they tell
you that but you don't see much of it
you have to go seek it out right and
that was always the case like that was
what's cool about mass effect one two
three and some parts of andromeda some
of the characters at least i've found
but i see it
yeah maybe
i just i haven't seen a lot of examples
and like the the example i think of
right now doesn't come till later but i
think it's a pretty cool example of how
they are
struggling yeah but i mean i don't know
i don't think it capitalizes on the cool
premise that it has right away and i
don't think
it feels more like this like almost like
third person
the story they're telling seems very
separate from the gameplay is my main
problem and that
has been my case throughout but again
you're farther in but maybe it'll get
better for me but at all at the same
time if i'm 12 hours in and it's still
not grabbing me then i don't want to be
keep playing well from what i've seen
and from what i've heard talking to
different people it sounds like
depending on what you get distracted by
and what you choose to do you could be
having a vastly better or worse
experience with it um because a lot of
people i know have been playing for a
while uh have been like oh yeah it
really opened up and like it started out
with like a rocky start and the combat
was great but everything else was a
little rough and then you know i met
this character and it was really cool
and i had this cool arc um but if you
decide to do a bunch of other [ __ ]
you're gonna miss all of that and then
you're gonna have a really bad you know
you could have a bad 30 hours um and i
think that's probably the main problem
is you
i mean patricia's metaphor is really
accurate where it's like if you just
follow the wrong trail if you have this
overwhelming email inbox and you find
something that's really bad and you keep
doing that and you never get rewarded
you're gonna get burnt out really
quickly um and to go back to the like a
zelda comparison the reason it's
different is you get rewarded
consistently um you can get very
distracted that game is very
overwhelming but you are all almost
always rewarded by what you do um and i
think that's probably a big problem
uh with andromeda i also i mean i just i
really can't shake the
the the dialogue is just unfortunately
very amateurish
um like there's a there's a character
who basically gives you her life story
and she's just like you meet her and
she's like oh well i'm trans and like
and it's like that's
i appreciate the effort but like that's
just so
like
your first creative writing effort um
and that really is so disappointing when
that's why i would want to play a mass
effect game i just can't shake that even
though i really do enjoy the combat and
exploration is cool and i like the
universe and i love space like
that's just really hard for me to to get
past i want to chime in as someone who
really has not really cared about mass
effect at all um
so
you know we say not to compare it to
games like zelda or whatever but for me
i think it is possible to make
comparisons there not direct ones but
you know coming off of games like
horizon zelda persona 5 near like
those games make excellent first
impressions
the the four hours i played of mass
effect andromeda
did nothing to excite me it only pushed
me away from the game and trying to play
it felt like i was forcing myself to do
something i really didn't want to do i
think first impressions are very
important and this game honestly really
fails at doing that so i you know as
someone who's who doesn't have like an
understanding of what the series can do
and what it's been great at in the past
like it's there's a huge barrier there
because if you don't have that those
hopes and wishes what do you don't know
what to look forward to like the combat
starts off very basic and in my opinion
boring right the game throws a lot of
systems at you like okay here's how you
upgrade all your profiles here has
become a different warrior here all the
skills doesn't explain any of it the ui
is a mess the animations look like crap
like i i could just go on and on and i
don't want to hate for the sake of
hating but there's something to be said
for a game that can't make an argument
for itself immediately like
i every game i just mentioned you know
other than this
there was something that made me
multiple things that made me want to
keep playing where like i couldn't put
the controller down like
that that's a huge problem this game has
and i think that's probably a reason why
people may be struggling to to really
get into it because it takes so long to
justify what it's trying to do
yeah i mean to it's not an rpg but
looking at another recent game night in
the woods with its writing grabbed me
within like two minutes yeah it doesn't
have to be an rpg like i think you can
compare games just on what they do in
general and how good they are at being a
captivating experience that gets you
excited to to be in that world to play a
part in it i was just thrust into this
pathfinder position suddenly i'm in
charge of everything
off like just right off the bat with
like an event that's just really ham
fisted
and then like
the game is sort of ushering me around
and i don't feel like i've earned my
position i don't feel like the things
i'm doing are building up to anything
really i mean look at witcher 3 that's a
massive game it's also an rpg but i was
i mean you it takes a while to really
get momentum in that game right but it's
not it's still right away like you get a
really good sense of the world i think
they're making good use of making me
feel like i'm part of it uh i get a
sense of geralt i get a sense of the
people around him like jennifer or uh
what's his
master's name
vasamir thank you mister 400 hours in
that game or no more than that now than
that for playthrough
yeah 800 sorry we talk about that all
the time but uh yeah i don't know i
again i said the other day and it seemed
to resonate i was like i could have
played
an entire playthrough of night in the
woods and it in the time it took me to
get into mass effect yes i want to touch
on night in the woods a little bit um i
read an article yesterday i think it was
on waypoint um forgive me for not
knowing who wrote it but it was about uh
awkward dialogue that's natural and how
night in the woods really masters that
and how uh
when we're speaking we very rarely um
speak perfectly the way we want to write
you don't really reform a sentence and
rewrite a sentence and what night in the
woods does really well is the dialogue
is
naturally very awkward like may's just
kind of like i don't know man
and um it feels like how you would talk
to somebody versus
the writing in in mass effect is awkward
in a an unnatural way if that makes
sense um like there's a scene where
you're flirting and she's just like i
think you're cute and i like having you
around and i'm like
no one says no one says that um and uh
so the the writing night in the woods um
is
like i just want to highlight that
difference like it's not awkwardness
that's the problem it's it's the
is it something that a person would
actually say um and that goes the
opposite way if you have somebody who's
perfectly articulating themselves all
the time and is always eloquent that's
also very unnatural um and so you have
to find a good balance when you're
writing dialogue it's very hard for a
lot of writers because you're used to
crafting
beautiful sentences you're used to
retooling a sentence
i think that's definitely harder to sell
on a triple a game though to make like
things like mass effect the original
mass effect series like had a lot of
tight dialogue but i think it also left
room for that kind of awkward kind of
like i i was actually looking at the
script for reboot today and you bring up
like that scene where tally is drunk
yeah and i think like
yeah like a night in the woods is a
different case in a sense because i feel
like you can do something like that you
can make it awkward all mass effect you
have a tight narrative that you're
trying to tell and you need to have like
the characters need to say what they
need to say yeah but i do agree that
like massive mass effect andromeda just
like can
not get like it just takes itself way
too seriously
it's been filtered too many times
exactly yeah yeah
um but i guess the overarching question
do you think with dlc or i mean
obviously there will be patches that
will fix a lot of the technical bugs but
with dlc with expansions and whatnot do
you think they'll improve the like the
core things we have wrong like maybe
they did with destiny
no
i don't think so either i
i think that i hope they do they can fix
something i'm trying to be positive
physics stuff like that like sure that's
possible they're not gonna go in and
redo animations unless someone forgot to
check a box like oh right their eyebrows
are supposed to move let's put that back
in the game
[Music]
i think that like yeah animations i
don't think they're gonna fix that i
think bugs they'll fix that i think dlc
has the potential to
redeem
some of the writing i know one thing
about dragon age was inquisition i
didn't play all of it but i do know that
the dlc was some of the best
in inquisition one of the best parts of
inquisition sorry i'm just imagining a
dlc in which
bioware goes back to when ryder is
taking her sats and you find out she
scored like a 20 or like oh that now her
personality makes sense i get it that's
why she
he or she is dumb
but but i i do think that they can
at least for fans who like stuck with
andromeda like me who's even though i'm
not in love with it i'm sticking with it
i think they can redeem it through some
really tight well-written
dlc uh whether that'll happen i don't
know i hope it does but as a whole like
i don't think they're gonna do anything
to bring someone like peter back or mike
who is a fan of the other games
yeah i mean i i was just telling pete
this is part of a wider thing i'm i've
been really good lately about
you know like unless i was reviewing
things back last year i don't review
anything anymore and obviously it's
different if you have to review a game
but now that i'm kind of looking at like
doing different things i'm better about
not forcing myself through a game i
really don't like
which i realize that's you know
i i am lucky enough to have access to a
lot of games for my job so i have a lot
of options but i'm also like i feel like
i need to beat andromeda but i'm really
trying to get myself not to because
i don't i don't see the point and i
don't think it's pulling me through and
i don't think it's worth it yeah i don't
know like if it's gonna take you 60
hours and like a lot of that isn't good
like yeah i don't think it's worth it
but you know like at least i would wait
until
they patch at least a little bit of
what's wrong with it but i don't think
it's gonna fix it you know intrinsically
like uh you know like destiny like kelly
mentioned destiny 10 king was a really
good example i think that actually and
that's that's different because destiny
is they said from the beginning bungie
was saying destiny is almost like a
platform in itself rather than a
singular discrete game mass effect
itself is very linear like you were
saying narrative like game and then sql
trilogy it's not really something that's
constantly evolving the way destiny is
or like just any multiplayer game
nowadays um but i do think that destiny
did a really good job of addressing
major problems and also
just like smaller things that people
were just really bothered by and then
that came through they got a new voice
actor and they rewrote some of his
dialogue and it was awesome um but yeah
i don't see stuff like that happening
for andromeda because i think the
problems are deeper than just what
destiny had yeah i mean i think like i
said this before but i'd be able to
overlook almost every issue if i like if
the writing and dialogue and characters
are good
definitely because there are people out
there that like the game yeah to clarify
like i don't it's like jean-luc psy like
jake's like kind of lukewarm
you know scott still had a good time in
the end i think and you know like it's
just a matter of
preferences at this point so read the
reviews uh
decide for what you will
i don't like the game doesn't mean you
don't have to
pete doesn't really like it doesn't mean
you have to
callie's gonna play more or no i'm yeah
i'm gonna play more i'm pretty i'm
pretty on the fence right now cool
all right so
that was our mass effect andromeda to
talk about you know like whether it can
be fixed in the future based on like the
other aaa games with rough launches that
we mentioned so let us know what you
think do you like bioware sorry do you
like mass effect andromeda do you like
what bioware montreal has done with this
because i know there are a lot of people
out there that are enjoying this game
for what it is um and also you know just
let us know what you think they could do
in the future feasibly to fix this i do
have one question i want to get on
really quick scott
rabideau on twitter i believe um thank
you for sending a question he says is a
new mass effect trilogy pretty much
guaranteed at this point like haven't
they said this is going to be
or no have sorry haven't they said
andromeda could be a standalone
experience
yeah so it sounds like they said it
could be a standalone experience but
scott who's finished it said there's
definitely room i mean yeah that's
that's what they would do that's like
business yeah so i i mean i don't think
we're gonna get like a trilogy in terms
of like mass effect one two and three
where your decisions or whatever carry
over but wrap up our show but like i
said if you're watching this on youtube
or gamespot let us know in the comments
what you think about uh mass effect
andromeda you can go read scott
butterworth's review i give it a six out
of ten that is up on gamespot right now
on sunday at 3 p.m
uh jake and i we have the third episode
of our show reboot going up it's uh i'll
get more in depth of my opinion more
specifically or i guess broadly about
science fiction in uh video games and
just movies in general and whatnot and
also why i don't think andromeda kind of
does science fiction well that's not
necessarily jake's opinion too it's
mainly mine but
well yeah you can go watch that but uh
yeah like i said let us know you think
about the game in the comments
all right man man i really want to play
i was telling john luke and like you
mentioned this
kelly was saying uh what ukulele made
you want to play banjo and you don't
know if that's a good thing yet yeah
that's how i feel about drama that makes
me want to play mass effect 2 i really
want to play too
anyway all right uh yeah to reiterate
begin the show i mentioned uh and shiva
who's in charge of our twitter had said
in the chat that uh you know you can go
to gamespot's twitter
follow it if you don't retweet the tweet
about the giveaway we have these this
can you grab these again sorry we have a
dota 2 mouse and mouse pad uh like we
have that library of collector's
editions stuff here the nick moore nick
margarita memorial library as we like to
call it jake and cali are going to model
these the sick
merchandise uh you can get later on the
week we'll pick a winner and uh maybe
that'll be you if you retweet that tweet
by gamespot and uh yeah so i don't know
if you're playing dota 2
recently then uh maybe these will be
good for that i don't know the mousepad
only works with dota 2. the mouse pad
only works with dota 2 so be careful
yeah uh anyway but yeah you can do that
uh and that's pretty much our show um
you're going to portland this weekend
for your birthday yeah happy
early birth what is the opposite of
belated buff early
yeah happy but early birthday birthday
thank you callie you're playing ukulele
mass effect what else are you doing
weekend plans it's only wednesday but
if you plan ahead oh i'm going to a
house cooling party oh oh cause it's
someone
that's moving out right yeah yeah it's a
former game spot editor actually yes
there's alexa korea yeah she's moving so
she's having a house cooling party then
at her party and there's gonna be a
clothes exchange it's gonna be a whole
thing wait what all the girls are
bringing old clothes oh i thought you
meant like
simul like you go and you all exchanged
clothes at the party i was like
there's a word for that kind of party
okay uh jake what about you uh
i'm filming something
yeah just for for school
oh really i thought you were trying to
reboot it i was like we've talked enough
about it it's not exciting it's all
right cool
and enjoying the new setup and we're
really happy when it's in the twitch in
the youtube chats and have a good week
and until then we'll see you reese's
best girl
[Music]
but leave